τα τελευταία χρόνια ότι η κύπρος δεν είναι μέσως ώρο είναι λίδε είναι πρώτη και
εκείνο που μιώθο εγώ είνα ότι σίγουρα τω να είσαι πρτος μεγάλον επίτευμα τω α
παραμείνεις όμως πρώτος τούτων που είπα πριν κουρτούρα ν επιτυχίας εκάτι το οποίον τώρα πρέπει
να συνεχίσουμε να δουλεύουμε δεν είναι αρκεδό τηλε ότι καταφέραμε τοκοσιένα και το κριο να
είμαστε το πιο γρήγορο δίκτιο της ευρώπης το κτέρα τοσπτετοιέξι που θα είμαστε πρώτη πρέπει
να βρούμε αυτούς τους τόμις για να διακριθούμε τος πο κάτι άλλων οι κύπρος για
τι στηλεπι κιωνισή κύπρος αυτή τη στιγμή έχει δκατρία υποβρήχεια καλότδια που συνδέοτι με την
κύπρο που συνδέω μάλλω την κύπρο με το εξωτεριγό με όλες τις χώρες τις περιοχής
αυτό είναι πολύ που μεαλύτερος αριθμός από των μέσων ώρον αλλο χωρών η ελλάδα για
να καταλάβετε μέχρι πρόσφαγα ι δύο καλόδια είχει η κύπρος με τη πολύ χρόνη προσπάθει
τησίδα τ τελευταία ίκωσ χρόνια και έχουμε πετύχει να συνδέσουμε την κύρο με όλες με
όλη την περιοχή και να είμαστε κόμβος επιτηλευικοινωνιών αυτό που θέλω από είναι ότι είμαστε
πολύ καλύτερα στις τηλεπικοινωνίες από ότι κάποιος θα περίμενε ένα μικρόνηση όπως ενι κύπρος να
είναι πρόκληση είναι να μείνουμε γέτες να μη χάσουμε αυτή την θέση και αυτό θέλει
πολύ περιοττερι δουλια και πλέον αλλάζει και τερικειτά υτότητα αλλά δεν αλλάζει απλώσηκώνα έτσι νομίζωύπατε
και στην ομιλία σας πρόσφαση μια κλετι να αυτό παλάζει η κυριενεο κλές σηαξιςήτα πωσου
είπα και πρι έχει λλάξει τατι τα τελευταία χρόνια έχουμε να αλλάξει πάρα πολλά το
μόνο που δεν είχε ν αλλάξει ήταν α τυπικά ηκών το σλόκα νιώθαμε ότι έπραπε
πρώτα να κάνουμε έργο να αλλάξουμε την ουσί